you know a video that [__] me up the
other day I saw a video where like it
was an interview apparently this is a
lot of people have this uh with someone
who doesn't have an internal monologue
oh yeah I've heard of this yeah I
[__] wish I could turn mine off I
never [__] shut the [__] up like I
cannot comprehend how your mind
functions yeah without like an inner
voice yeah so like if you're sitting
there not talking to anyone are you just
in complete silence
people just making this [__] up
conspiracy it's gonna be there's gotta
be some people making this [__] up well
what if what if they do actually have an
in a voice but it's just real like the
volumes down to like one and they just
can't hear
that's not yeah I mean I don't know my
[__] monologue doesn't have a volume
you never know
apparently some people don't have one
which is even weirder in my opinion yeah
I got like they were talking about
reading right they were talking about
how they read stuff yeah and I would
they were like I saw this video and it
was like they were explaining that they
recognized the shape of the word I do
that uh and then with the shape of the
words there's a certain flow to the
shape that they recognize and they
internalize and [__] like that I do that
you do that yeah
no I do I don't read the words I read
the shape yeah but do you hear the words
when you read like when you read
something he [__] hears the word I do
what the [__] you don't hear you don't
hear what if I'm looking at this right
I'm looking at this I'm not I'm not
saying it out loud but in my head I'm
saying out loud strong zero uh
I mean I guess sometimes I would but not
all the time I mean now that I'm now
you're telling me to do it I'm doing it
but I don't think I would normally do
that I think I would just clock it as
strong zero I mean I wouldn't say it in
my head you can't hear it but when
you're like reading a sentence like when
are you like let's say you're reading
the shittiest YouTube comments oh yeah
yeah I'll read it out of my head okay
okay here's another question when you're
reading a really stupid YouTube comment
or a really stupid tweet do you have
like a voice in your head that like
reads it helpful hell yeah or do you
read out the sentence and then you find
it funny let's just read it my own voice
no I read it I read in a dumb voice
you're like this video was so stupid I
hated it unsubscribed just like I think
with some of these these things right
like yeah yeah like people they get
they're like I they go on forums like I
saw this this video game one time and
then this happened can you guys help me
find it and then it turns out it never
existed yeah but everyone's like oh I
know that game I think this [__] happens
yeah uh no it's different that's
different that's why people misremember
something oh yeah yeah
um but like they actually just everyone
just fabricates a game and they all kind
of have very uh sparse memories and
Collective experiences I think this is
what happens sometimes with this stuff I
think people hear pieces of something
they're like oh I have that too and
obviously there's no way we can
scientifically prove or be like yes you
have it or not we're just going on the
word of people you know saying it yeah
and let's be honest
if someone found out they'd get a little
bit of attention from making something
up I think some people would do it let's
be real let's be real come on people
make shut up let's not pretend that we
don't live in a world we don't make [__]
up uh for no reason like there's people
who are like oh yes my body is uh
magnetic I live next to mine it makes
magnetic and they put like spoons on
their nose and they're like what's wrong
with you
this is not a me thing this is the thing
that people do where they claim to be
magnetic and they just stick the spoons
and the forks on their body [__] are you
talking about it sounds like the
weirdest Favorite Dream Of My Life I
genuinely can't believe you've never
heard it no because that's so easy to
disprove yeah people are dumb as [__]
bro this is so common I can't I can't
believe you I genuinely am in shock
you've never heard of this fall into
this Rabbit Hole this has been on like
mainstream TV for like 20 or 30 years
I've never heard of this this is so like
people fake it all the [__] time I
know people fake it all the [__] time
but like you know it's always a decency
to like fake something that is either
really difficult to prove or just
straight up impossible maybe they just
want attention people want attention
they make [__] up all the time oh yeah
of course there's no difference between
somebody's faking and someone who
generally believes it and just dumb
uh I believe it's the same thing
no no no no no
some people do like performances or
shows like look I'll stick things to my
body turns out I'm just sweaty it's like
no there's double-sided tape on this
thing yeah [__] in it it's [__] awful
I mean that it's a difference between
like a scam and someone who uh you know
is really believing in what they are
doing but is yeah scientifically wrong
yeah well you know it's like you see
flat earthers actually believe it yeah
they do 100 they do I'd like to hope not
I absolutely do you know I've seen
they absolutely do right so yeah it's
not like a nefarious kind of like
uh strong people it's not as well
there's some smart people who believe in
that [__] and it's like sad because it's
like they just get in this mindset and
then you know we're really bad at being
when we believe something being proven
otherwise yeah just as humans in general
no yeah so I think there's just a lot of
that at play and it sucks because again
you see some of these like really smart
dudes who are really put together who
are like I'm gonna disprove it and they
do a science experiment that proves that
the Earth is round obviously because it
[__] is yeah
um and it's like wow such a smart person
who could put together an experiment
that would actually prove if the Earth
was flat or not and they disproved
themselves and they still don't believe
it uh that's weird but also I don't know
I don't know the mental chemistry that's
going on there where you get faced with
evidence and you're like no
because if someone shows me that I'm
wrong on something like scientific I'd
be like all right it happens all the
time like if someone shows me I'm like
that food poisoning is really an illness
I'll believe them I mean I ain't she not
that happens all the time in trash days
you tell me pizza crusts are good I'm
like no you're wrong and right that's
like my truth well that's subjective
yeah it's crazy to me that like yeah I
don't know it's crazy to me that like I
used to talk we talked about it about it
and other stuff like people I believe
historical events didn't happen it's
like we have so much proof it's like you
think someone faked it bro okay I don't
know that's weird well
if what if the evidence it's fake which
it sometimes is you know there's a great
uh we all know NASA fake the moon
there's a great Veritas video where
there have actually been many
conspiracies conspiracy theories that
were proven correct like we there are
situations where sometimes it is valid
to believe a conspiracy theory and then
that's part of the issue is that that
you can never really rule stuff out yeah
but that's the problem it's like once
one conspiracy theory that has made its
way around the world has at the end of
it all proven to be true then that
validates every other conspiracy theory
to be like see this one was right and
that was that was labeled as a
conspiracy theory but which means that
our Theory which you guys call
conspiracy theories has a leg up in this
conversation because this one was proven
true when in reality it's just one
anomaly also it's just nice just to let
your imagination run wild sometimes
sometimes reality is just boring and
it's just like not like a lot of times
the boring explanation is the right one
maybe I think it's yeah it's satisfying
to feel like you figured something out
that not everyone else did I was in an
Uber in uh L.A because of course
there's a guy and you know I
you know being a white guy I feel like I
attract the the crate like a lot of the
crazy like white where are you going
with this feel way more comfortable
opening up to me about the crazy and I
also don't judge because I'm like I
actually want to hear what they have to
say yeah yeah uh because I find it very
amusing
so this guy starts going on about
something you know you say oh you're
from England that's nice it's nice he's
like yeah well because I mentioned yeah
England sorry the UK so yeah he's in the
UK oh that's nice that's nice thing you
know the us is going to be a lot better
when the war's over I'm like I'm like
yeah man I guess the the whole Ukraine
thing is pretty pretty bad right now huh
it's not I'm not going too well he's
like no no the war happened in the US I
was like this war happen in the US he's
like
well I don't want to get too much into
it because I don't know why you lie and
I'm like well I'm always interested to
learn and to be corrected
um because I just want to hear what he
has to say so I'm trying to like tell
them that like you're entertaining him
yeah yeah man I I get you he's like well
he basically went on like the whole Nano
machines rant like Nano machine son
um instead of being like the inside
government yada yada and was like uh
tell me about it and he's like you know
I just
the global warming thing I think is just
a huge scam and I go well yeah but uh
why did you buy a Tesla then
he's like well the features are just
great I was like yeah but I mean surely
you wouldn't get the electric and he's
like oh you know and I felt like I was
losing him so I was like hey you're
right you're right you're right yeah but
he's just going off and on and on and on
and he seemed like a really nice guy
initially and like we're all put
together he started going off about
cabals in the government and I was like
just miseducated yeah what do you seemed
like a rather intelligent guy but he
kept going about vibrations and [__] and
I was like what happened to you